so I've talked about the gas lighting that
has been carried out either deliberately or
accidentally by the current administration.
I told you that in 2020 I'm going to do everything
I can to prevent the gas sliding
from attaching to society.
And I have to start today by telling you that
Donald Trump is claiming that one of his greatest
honors was doing something that he just didn't
do.
Something that was done five almost six years
ago, that actually it was Bernie Sanders and
the late John McCain, uh, and Barack Obama
that did it.
The thing, this is so absurd that it is, again,
I find myself wanting to use that language.
This is almost unreal, but I want to be careful
because as I told you, I don't want to normalize
this.
It sounds unreal, but it is not.
Donald Trump is claiming that his greatest
honor at the end of 2019 he said, was getting
veterans choice approved choice was a bill
by Bernie Sanders and John McCain, which Barack
Obama signed into law.
This is stunning, but it's real and it's unacceptable.
Here's Donald Trump's tweet just four hours
before the end of 2019 quote, one of my greatest
honors was to have gotten choice approved
for our great veterans.
Others have tried for decades and failed.
The veterans choice act was signed into law
in 2014 by then president Barack Obama.
Here is a picture of Barack Obama signing
this into law.
You see Bernie Sanders standing right next
to Barack Obama.
The bill was sponsored by senators Bernie
Sanders and John McCain years ago.
Donald Trump did not do this.
Now, does Donald Trump not know that he didn't
do this?
Is he deliberately, deliberately lying?
I don't know why Donald Trump is saying this
is unclear.
Now Donald Trump did expand eligibility for
veterans choice.
You can say, well, that's a good thing and
that's fine, but Donald Trump is lying or
clueless when he says that this has been a
failure for decades, which he then was able
to accomplish.
What Trump did is make some tweaks and they're
fine tweaks where veterans would be allowed
to go to private doctors.
If the wait for a VA doctor is more than 20
days before Trump, it was 30 days.
Trump reduced it to 20 days.
That's great.
Uh, Donald Trump, uh, changed the eligibility
so that veterans are allowed to see a private
doctor.
If the closest VA facility is more than 30
minutes away.
Previously it was 40 miles.
Uh, these are fine changes, but they are merely
tweaks.
This is gaslighting or lying or something.
Trump is the first to claim credit for things
that he didn't actually do and will never
take responsibility for his blunders or his
failures.
It's like they don't exist.
This is a very narcissistic way to lead, but
it's working for Donald Trump, and this is
where the challenge comes to us in 2020 the
gaslighting works for Trump.
People want to believe what Donald Trump is
telling them if they voted for him because
they want to feel justified somewhere deep
down, they recognize their vote for Trump
was a blunder.
It was a self-destructive act.
It was an embarrassing act on the national
stage.
So they are primed to take whatever Trump
says, even if it's demonstrably false, like
I accomplished veteran's choice.
No, you didn't.
It was Bernie and John McCain signed in by
Barack Obama five, six years ago.
You didn't do it.
They don't care.
They want to believe it.
And I got a, an email from a veteran who said,
I have a veteran's choice card in my wallet.
I've had it for years.
Trump didn't just do this.
The card says 2014 on it.
It says nothing about Trump.
Trump was a reality host at the time that
I received a card for a program that he is
now trying to take credit for.
We can say it's sad.
We can say it's unreal or whatever, but we
can't let this stuff become normalized.
This is like if bill Clinton had said I did
a the new deal.
No, you didn't.
FDR did it 50 years ago.
This is equally bonkers.
We can't let them get away with it, and unfortunately
his followers are in a state where they are
more than willing, willing is not a strong
enough term.
They welcome letting Trump get away with it
because they want to be convinced of this
stuff may be just as much as Trump seems to
have convinced himself, it's a very sad state
of affairs for the country.
We can at least start trying to remedy it
with a voting to remove Donald Trump in just
10 months.
It's incredible.
We're just 10 months
from
the election.